the European Parliament's hosts a
science feast every year MEP s from stoa
the science and technology options
assessment panel invites eminent
scientists to present their research
this year the stage went to quantum
optics I think increasingly we're seeing
a need for better engagement between
scientists and policymakers we tend to
work in silos and welcome I'm for a week
chairman of Sister Committee one of the
guests was none other than the laureate
of the naval price of physics in 2012
for Sarah hush european research cannot
afford to rest on its laurels as way
aurora story continued as really
sincerely NASA de venta de vendas novas
shaundra creativity roxycontin yes here
theythey posey a particularly power
developed by external a big debate
Lazydays do I 12 a powerful entities I
percentage GDP story actions in V Leiden
avoid waking the operation on yon
bindiya trafico de Atocha Indyk suit
Corey equipped via potent ours anto damn
it this way that goes the VHF thraxton
erect m eps would like to see the budget
allocated to research doubled but this
desire may be hampered by EU budgetary
restrictions